- The truth is my father, I mean coach, is a malignant presence, a bully and bad at drafting.
Today, his reign ends.
- Nice play...my No. 1 boy.
- But I’m your actual son Steve Belichick.
- Oh, f--k off!
♪♪♪
- Wickersham is investigating potential dysfunction.
- There's no f--king dysfunction!
- Yeah, totally.
- F--king totally.
- Why do we all swear so f--king much?
- What if we go with MacCorkle?
- Mac's deep balls are f--king bad optics.
- Maybe it's Jarrett Stidham time?
- As acting CEO, maybe what I say—
- Oh, go get another f--king massage, Robert.
- Sorry, sir.
- Twitter looks positive. Calling the Bucs' Super Bowl a “big win”
and “proof Brady is genius, not Belichick.”
OK, Gronk think that KINDA an overreaction—
- F--K THE PATRIOTARCHY!
♪♪♪
- [Together:] Agreed!
- You mother—
♪♪♪
- P to the A-Y, and he’s a TON OF FUN. SEAN PAYTON!
- Taysom, you're my favorite.
♪♪♪
- All four on the floor!
- It's time.
- This doesn’t bother me.
- [Producer:] Hey, where’s Brady? The audience loves a sad, rich guy.
- Ayo, sorry I didn’t fit in with that whole Succession thing.
Those joyless winners get so angry.
Plus they got all that money, but all they wear are monochrome baseball caps!
Wear a top hat, old man! You rich!
Anyways, I’m BACCCCKKKK...
but ya’ll just gotta give me like a couple games first, man.